tomorrow is election day and off your
election in the state of virginia glenn
miller is an attorney from mclean right
across the river from washington
like most lawyers in the d.c suburbs
he's a loyal democrat in 2016 he voted
for hillary clinton last fall he voted
for joe biden and yet tomorrow he says
he's voting for the republican glenn
younkin in the virginia governor's race
at a young rally over the weekend he
explained why
the tipping point miller told the new
york times came one day as he was
working from home and heard his teenage
daughter's teacher make a comment during
a virtual lesson about white men as
modern day slave holders
for glenn miller this was too much
there are a lot of people like me miller
said who were annoyed
and annoyed for good reason in virginia
as in the rest of the country democrats
have been yammering about race non-stop
specifically about the dangerous racism
of white people
literally without ceasing for the last
year and a half it's all they talk about
it's a kind of monomania
not surprisingly therefore questions
about race have dominated the virginia
governor's election and in a normal year
that would seem odd in this case both
candidates are white and the state
they're hoping to run doesn't
objectively speaking have a lot of race
problems virginians of all colors tend
to get along pretty well as they do
nearly everywhere in america no matter
what they tell you on cnn
and yet listening to terry mcauliffe
who's the democratic nominee you get the
impression it's 1855 in richmond as we
speak human beings are being auctioned
downtown
in terry mcauliffe's telling nothing has
changed in virginia
and so for months mcauliffe has offered
a one-word explanation for virtually
every question he's been asked and the
answer of course is racism
whatever terry mcauliffe doesn't like is
racist seriously terrifyingly racist
like slavery
on the other hand whatever terry
mcauliffe does like such as accumulating
more personal power for himself is by
definition the answer to racism in fact
the only answer
it's a very simple and very familiar
formula
it's also incredibly divisive not to
mention stupid and tiresome
the question tomorrow is are virginia
voters finally fed up with this garbage
does the race card still work is there a
single sane person who believes that
white racism is the root of all of the
state's problems
we're going to find out tomorrow
polls suggest that mcauliffe is going to
lose this race and if he does there's
going to be an earthquake within the
democratic party terry mcauliffe was the
governor of virginia just four years ago
joe biden won the state by 10 points
last november
the most famous democrats on the planet
from the sitting president joe biden to
the former president barack obama to
kamala harris herself have personally
campaigned for terry mcauliffe in the
state of virginia so the democratic
party has left nothing on the table and
there's a reason for that democrats
understand this election is a referendum
not simply on an amoral sleazeball who
wants to be the governor again for some
reason but a referendum on the
performance of our entire leadership
class a referendum on them
it didn't have to be this way if terry
mcauliffe had been wise enough to keep
this race non-ideological he would
without question have won it widen the
highways fix 66 lower the car tax
shorten your commute to work
make dulles airports slightly less
horrible
who wouldn't vote for those things
but no
instead of promising to improve the
lives of the people who live in virginia
mcauliffe instead found himself
defending joe biden's lunatic openly
racist equity agenda something that
unless you're directly benefiting from
it as a consultant
you probably hate
the equity agenda is rooted in hostility
and hatred it is immoral and on some
level most people understand that
perfectly well
and yet here was terry mcauliffe live on
television explaining that parents who
insist on having a role in their own
children's education must be white
supremacists
people trust me on education but it's at
the forefront here in virginia as it now
is in others you see what's happening
george and florida because they're
talking about this critical race theory
and as i said before and i'll say it
again it's never been taught in virginia
and i really hate it because it's a
racist dog whistle
terry mcauliffe never recovered from
that interview and the polls showed it
and he didn't recover because what he
said was a lie and everyone with
school-age children in virginia knew it
was a lie and if you're interested take
a look at the virginia apartment
education's website right now quote
teachers must embrace theories such as
critical race theory settler colonialism
black feminism disability critical race
studies and other critical theories
that's from a book the state of virginia
recommends
that book goes on to instruct teachers
to avoid phrases like work hard or be
nice because those are expressions of
white settler colonialism there are
other examples of this the virginia
department of education also promotes
race hustler ibram x kendi formerly
known as henry rogers
kendi has gotten quite rich by inflaming
the masochism of affluent white liberals
the people who love to be told they're
powerful and naughty as they send their
kids to private school
it tells you how low their standards are
that ibram kendy has done all of this
despite being stupid how stupid this is
an actual tweet candy sent over the
weekend quote
more than a third of white students lied
about the race on college applications
and about half of these applicants lied
about being native american more than
three-fourths of these students who lied
about their race were accepted
oh
so in other words ibrahim x kendi is
telling us america is such a white
supremacist country that white kids
can't even get into college without
pretending not to be white
right
so eventually gear's turning slowly
kendy realized that tweet might not be
helping his case and so he deleted it
but the point remains these are the
people providing the education to
children in virginia and if you live
there that's a problem even if you're a
democrat
so no wonder glenn younkin is winning
it's all too much
and yet interestingly weirdly terry
mcauliffe has not corrected course he
has instead doubled down on this stuff
which again no one really likes
at a campaign event just last night
mcauliffe told the crowd that he's
identified the actual problem in
virginia schools and you'll never guess
what it is
it's too many white teachers
and we've got to work hard diversify our
teacher base 50 of our students our
students of color 80 percent of the
teachers are white
now to his credit mcauliff's opponent
glenn yunken who has really improved
with every day of this campaign as
people do sometimes in these campaigns
has called this kind of rhetoric for
what it is it's a racial attack it's
also an assault on the founding
principles of the united states which to
sum up is the christian belief that all
people regardless of their skin color
are equal before god
but friends let me be clear one of the
things we're not going to do in our
schools is teach our children to view
everything through a lens of race
we know it's not right we know in our
heart i mean
we're all of one body of christ how in
the world can we teach our children to
be divided up into buckets with one
group being privileged another group
being being victims that's just not
right it steals their dreams we know
that so let me just be clear on day one
i will ban critical race theory it will
not be in our schools
i just won't
well exactly nicely put i mean these
ideas aren't just annoying they're
poison and they end with rwanda and
anyone who thinks it through understands
that if you wanted to unite the country
which badly needs to be united you would
emphasize our equality of value
we may be different in many ways and we
are
but we are all worth the same
period and anyone who doesn't believe
that should not be within a hundred
yards of power ever
unfortunately for the rest of us the
racial unity message which we so badly
need does not get democrats elected
so last week democrats in virginia
concocted yet another fake race hoax to
make voters hate each other and increase
their electoral advantage
democratic political operatives posing
as neo-nazis showed up outside a
glenyonkan event carrying torches they
stayed long enough to be photographed by
a credulous local reporter and then
terry mcauliffe's campaign team
circulated pictures of those alleged
white supremacists claiming they were
yunkan supporters he's a racist
many members the media did the same of
course
and then within hours the lie collapsed
and that's when we learned that the
lincoln project was or they said they
were behind this watch
you're getting crushed by people on the
right as a dirty tactic do you stand
behind what was done and is that being
what you guys say you oppose
um no listen every day uh i hear people
pleading with the lincoln project to
help show democrats how to win how to
play hardball um
you know this is an example
so they've told us for 10 months that
january 6 was a nazi rally they're nazi
rallies everywhere it's a lie there
aren't there aren't any nazi rallies in
this country ever because there's not
that much racism in this country because
it's a really nice country but they have
to tell us that there are and at this
point they had to make one up so they
staged a fake nazi rally
so you have to ask yourself
who's spreading hate in america
well they are
and then you've got to wonder under the
current rules to which we're all subject
why is the lincoln project still on
twitter and facebook has bank of america
closed its accounts on moral grounds as
they've done to so many people on the
right
are these creeps at the lincoln project
some of whom apparently covered for
their child molester colleague are they
still allowed on paypal and gofundme of
course they are have their donors been
doxed and exposed and driven from their
jobs in their homes
no
some of their biggest and donors include
hollywood film producer david geffen
he's given him a half a million dollars
hollywood film producer jeffrey
katzenberg has given him a hundred grand
gordon getty son of oil tycoon j paul
getty has donated a million dollars to
the lincoln project
all of these people are funding a group
that staged a nazi rally and blamed
their a political opponent and then
didn't have the decency to apologize for
it
now that's a story
but it's not being covered instead the
media spent the weekend obsessing over
whether a southwest airline pilot may or
may not have offended joe biden over the
pa system and if so put that man in jail
so they're trying their best at every
level they are trying their best to drag
professional sleazeball terry mcauliffe
across the finish line in virginia and
despite all these efforts the lying the
misdirection a lot of people in the
state and not just republicans realize
what's actually happening and who's
behind it
tomorrow they can send a very clear
signal to the people doing it stop
dividing us by race stop indoctrinating
our school children to hate us stop
treating parents like domestic
terrorists this is not about whether a
republican or a democrat wins tomorrow
this is about where we go from here as a
country hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else